put it out the way it was written i when
i made some edits but i i just wanted it
to be in the voice of an authentic 19
year old because we don't listen to 19
year olds we don't listen to young
people young people have problems
some of them are very suicidal as you
know and and i want and i confront these
these nightmares
i had them
you were having suicidal thoughts at 19.
oh yeah really very much so yeah do you
know the divorces before the war right
the divorce was successful
that's what i'm saying was it divorced
alienation i didn't know what to do in
my life i was lost really lost
which is i'm trying to explain why i
actually volunteered to go to this
vietnam
combat because it was the only there was
nothing else for me it was the way to
maybe solve this issue if i was going to
off myself i didn't want to do it
it would be done
perhaps for me by the forces you know in
vietnam wow so i was willing to you know
willing to die i thought
when i got there of course you know
after infantry training i got pretty i
got put into the 25th infantry and
in uh september of 67 so it was right as
the war was getting to its hottest point
and i i served in
three different units
i ended up at the first cavalry because
i got wounded twice in the 25th
i went through the all the stuff in
south saigon then i went up to and
then i moved on to camp evans
in guangxi province so i had quite a bit
of experience there
and so saw a fair share of combat and uh
came back to the states
as
disillusioned i suppose very
disillusioned i realized i wanted to
live because i didn't want to i didn't i
saw a lot of death and i didn't want to
die
uh uh
you you said something earlier to me
before we talked about the i've yet when
i said something about vietnam i came
back deadened dead
numb
i didn't know who i was what i was i was
uh totally it's a problem for returning
veterans as you know in any war any
place you know
our society was not geared to war our
society people were not
enlisting or
volunteering by any means most people
were avoiding it in my class
at yale and
hill school all of these people would
most of them were not going there
it was considered
that was for uh poor people right and
that that bothered me so i got my first
real strong experience of living with
the
call it the lower class americans but
they were really good people and i had
had much there were many good people
there and at the same time i got to know
our black population pretty pretty well
because
i found them to be very powerful in my
experience there they uh in a way they
they helped keep me alive kept me human
the music going back to the base camp
smoking dope that kind of stuff in the
rear is very important and keeps you
it keeps you human and i've discovered
soul music and it was just
a good relationships
whereas
some other people have problems over
there they they
you can let ward you can let war finish
you off it makes you very callous very
callous
there was a racist war in the sense yeah
many many of us mistreated the
vietnamese didn't look didn't respect
him at all the soldiers you mean yeah
yeah
so and that was a you see that overall
in our
attitudes towards third world people
and uh i saw a lot of that i didn't like
it at all
so
i'm giving you a long narrative no this
is i wrote a book about it it's called
uh
chasing the light and uh about my first
40 years and i i i told that story
because vietnam plays a huge role in in
america's destiny which is where i'm
going to go to in the in my lifetime my
father being a republican
uh being pro vietnam at one point uh
very much he was an intelligent man he
wasn't a he was an economist wall street
man
he uh he
he was very passionate in his views and
he stated them publicly he was a writer
and
today among other things he was he wrote
a monthly monthly investment letter for
his firm
and it was a very popular letter so he
was given the gift of expression he was
a very good writer
i admired him
didn't agree with him we fought like dog
and cat after the war because he he
didn't really respect to vietnam he to
him world war ii was the war he was a
lieutenant colonel
you understand the
dichotomy and here i was a pot-smoking
long-haired hippie type coming back from
this war but i wasn't a hippie i was
just
a screwed up
veteran you know
so
after a long period of drugs and this
and that i ended up back at nyu on the
gi bill
which is where uh i went to film school
and because what else you know what else
could i do
didn't have any skills except
how to how to fire a rifle how to how to
build a fire how to live outdoors in the
jungle that was one those were my skills
so i went to uh
school for the for two years uh marty
scorsese was the youngest teacher there
i had him in a class and he was very
very he moved me and
all the teachers were very good school
was very sharp
learned a lot
wait how much how much further you want
me to go keep kee i'm actually very
interested please continue i'm actually
very interested in martin scorsese who
was your teacher at nyu you were saying
marty was a t yeah he was young
i want to know to the point of first
movie like i want to know to the point
of your first big movie and then winning
uh
an award for midnight
well that's a few years ahead i had to
go through a lot of
to a lot of uh rejection
from film school i mean you come out of
film school i was driving i drove a taxi
in new york
uh because that was there's
there was no jobs for phil it wasn't
younger people were not yet accepted the
way they have been since uh it was tough
uh drove a taxi it was a messenger i was
working in all temp jobs that i could
get
and i was writing i i kept writing i
remember i written a novel so i kept
writing screenplays my first screenplay
is 69
and it's a crazy it reads crazy but it's
part of the development of a writer you
have to go through all these i wrote
eight nine ten maybe eleven screenplays
over those next six seven years
and all of them were rejected
although two of them were finally
optioned and that led to some kind of
light
in in hollywood i started to meet some
people just off the options matt had
married a lebanese woman
who was very beautiful and uh
had a job at the u.n so i was she was
helping me uh
uh
i was living in her apartment we were
married and
nashua
lebanese i'm sure you you know uh
christian lebanese so uh
i i moved to hollywood
we divorced after seven years
together we and i moved to hollywood
and started over again i was very lucky
in the sense that
my first i got a job a higher job to
work on midnight express which was a
book
peter a big uh a hustling young producer
peter goober
at columbia wanted to make this movie
and of course the story was fascinating
about a turk a boy american boy from
long island was busted in turkey
and for hash
went to jail for uh
was sentenced to 30 years but uh it was
a quite a case and it went around and
around no it was first of all he was
sentenced for five years and then he was
resentenced for 30 years
the turkish uh system of justice at that
time was very strange uh and the ch and
the jail was hilarious because
if you had money in jail in turkey you
lived like a king but if you were just
part of the foreign riffraff
you lived pretty badly yeah
so uh you can imagine the contrast
uh
anyway the movie came out and it was a
gigantic hit
it was 1978 79
and i got an academy award that was the
most shocking crazy yeah so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]
you